Musik Das ist eigentlich deine einzige Aufgabe. Wäre ganz gut, wenn du das vielleicht so ein bisschen an dich ranholen würdest. Aber wir haben ja in deinem Lebenslauf gesehen, wir können ihn vielleicht auch mal gross machen. Du hast einen Mikrofon-Workshop belegt. Wie gut ist das denn? Wir haben mal eine Folge lang löschen müssen, die ganze Folge müs Folge mussten wir löschen, weil wir falsch, weil Florentin falsch in das Mikrofon gesprochen hat, er hat das einfach falsch rum und wir dachten, dass du uns heute mal als jemand, der ein Mikrofon im Workshop belegt hat, zeigen kannst, wie man richtig ein Mikrofon bespricht. Also ich weiss nur, wie man reinspricht, aber ich weiss nicht, wie rum ich das halten muss. Also ich hoffe immer, dass es richtig rum geht. Das lernt man dann im Mikrofon-Workshop zwei oder …?
Ja, zwei Punkt null.
Pocket, so im zweiten Teil. Ja, heute ist du bei uns zu Gast …
Doch, fang doch mal an.
Heute bei uns zu Gast Sabrina Sauer.
Herzlich willkommen, erst mal Stefan Titzel wie immer.
Titzel, hallo, bin auch da.
Flo Ding Will ist auch da.
Ein Oldie abgestaubt.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Sabrina Sauer kennt man wahrscheinlich eher von Geldscheinen, von anderen grossen Ereignissen. Name tatsächlich, als ich das erste Mal gehört habe, ich finde, der klingt ein bisschen ausgedacht. Es klingt so ein bisschen wie der deutsche Donnie Darko oder sowas. Siehst du dich auch so ein bisschen als sowas und wo kommt der Name her? Da waren meine Eltern, glaube ich, sehr kreativ. Meine Mama mochte Charlies Engel, hier drei Engel für Charlie, und da hieß, glaube ich, eine ganz dunkelhaarige Sabrina. Und eigentlich sollte ich ein Junge werden, deswegen musste die Namensfindung sehr schnell gehen. Sabrina Sauer. Ich hatte dunkle Haare, ja, ich sollte eigentlich ein Junge sein und dann beim Rauskommen war es dann kein Junge und dann hatte ich dunkle Haare und dann meinte meine Mutter, dunkle Haare ist das nicht die von hier. Aber dann bist du in der modernen Technik nicht schon vor der Geburt das Geschlecht rauszufinden? Die Haarfarbe? Ja, anscheinend schon, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hätte ich einen sehr grossen Daumen. Aber du musst dir einfach improvisieren. Grossen Daumen, ja. Bin blöd hingehalten. Das kenne ich, das höre's what she said. Kann ich das hier eigentlich runtermachen? Ja klar, ich seh euch gar nicht. Der Popschutz ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Wir haben einen riesen Popschutz. Ich spuck auch wenig. Und dadurch sieht man immer die Leute nicht, die dahinter sitzen. Aber wichtiger ist ja die Stimme eigentlich, deine engelszarte, hochdünne Stimme. Du bist ja eine der wenigen ausgebildeten Sprecherinnen, die überhaupt den Podcast haben. Das heißt, keine Versprecher, ganz klare Aussprache.
Stefan hat letztens... Ganz kurz, wie würdest du folgendes Wort aussprechen?
Ja.
Ist ein Tiername, und zwar am Strand liegt es manchmal rum.
Und es ist sehr wabbelig, das flimmt durch Wasser.
Wie nenn ein durchdächtiges Tier? Wie willst du es nennen?
Ich glaube, du hast es?
Boah, jetzt habe ich Angst.
Du hast es.
Kann ich das erstmal für mich selber?
Sag es mal laut. Nein! Qualle. Nochmal? Qualle. Also man spricht da schon ein W. Das ist ein leichtes. Fucking Qualle heißt das. Nicht Qualle. Ich habe immer Qualle gesagt und Frequenz. Und da hat jemand sich beschwert, dass ich das falsch ausgesprochen habe. Und der hat völlig recht. Da habe ich meine Sprachtrainerin aus meinem Studiengang gefragt. Und dann hat sie gesagt, das spricht man wie KW aus. Jetzt habe ich von oben bestätigt bekommen, dass es mit W ist, also offensichtlich ist das die richtige Lautsprache, Frequenz, Qualle, wusste ich nicht. Klang aber auch komisch, Frequenz klingt komisch. Ja. Okay, ja das sind beim Podcast immer solche Probleme dann einfach, dass Leute dann einfach sagen direkt, die spricht das so und so falsch aus, deswegen achte bitte darauf, dass du jedes Wort richtig aussprichst. Ich werde mir Mühe geben. Ja, das ist sehr wichtig. Gut, da wir jetzt eine angenehme, ganz natürliche Atmosphäre geschaffen haben, in der man einfach ganz natürlich alles raushaut. Wo kommst du her, was machst du, warum bist du hier? Ich komme aus Geboren, oder ich komme aus Aachen, so? Steht hier, wir haben deinen Lebenslauf offen, was echt lustig ist. Das stimmt, das kann ich auch mal aufhören. Das ist eine wirklich lustige Situation. Jetzt guckt ihr, ob ich da auch richtig oder ob ich mir jetzt was ausdenke. Ne, genau. Also wir wissen gar so ein Art Quiz, wir wollen wissen, ob du das bist. Hier hätte der Jäger hinkommen können jetzt. Ah, das stimmt. Der behauptet, der weiß, dass die Brina sauer. So, Aachen. So, Geboren am. Oh, das ist jetzt aber sehr intim. Das ist aber auch jetzt knifflig. Jahrestag musst du nicht sagen. Den 31. Juli gibt's auch überhaupt gar nicht. Wohl. Der Juli hat nur 30 Tage. Gar nicht. Schon erste falsche Antwort. Das kann man mit den Knöcheln zählen. Grösse 1,65. Das ist ein bisschen gelogen. Ich glaube, das sind zwei Zentimeter weniger. Ohne Schuhe. Du kommst in die meisten Achterbahnen nicht rein, korrekt? Ich glaube, die sind ab 1, doch ab 1,50. Dann ziehe ich mir Stoppersocken an oder so. Sehr grosse Stelzen kommen sie dann an. Buffalo. Setz sie einfach einen grossen Hut auf oder so eine Marge-Simpson-Frisur. War das nicht auch irgendwann mein Gag, dass Marge-Simpson auch so einen ganz langen Kopf hat, dass es gar nicht nur Frisur hat? Ach so, ja. Nee, weil manchmal hat sie ja, wenn die in die Vergangenheit springen, wo sie die Haare noch platt runter hat, da hat sie ja offensichtlich einen ganz normalen Kopf. Nee, ich glaube, es gibt diesen Gag, wo man ihr Gehirn, ihr Kopf sieht und dann ist er so inneren Monolog und dann so, du solltest das nicht tun und dann geht die Kamera so einen Schritt nach oben und irgendwann heisst sie noch, ich bin nur noch ein Haarbüschel, ich kann dir nicht mehr helfen oder irgendwas. Stimmt. Einfach, ja. Ja, die Simpsons sind schon so echt lustig. Sein Podcast besteht hauptsächlich daraus, andere Gags gut zu finden. Warte mal, ich stehe durch Dialekte drauf, Rheinisch und Plattdeutsch. Und Hebräisch kannst du anscheinend. Näh, ein bisschen. Das ist so weird, dass wir den Lebenslauf durchgehen. Das ist so seltsam. Ich hätte jetzt auch gerne euren. Kann ich euch nicht nur so gegenfragen. Aber es ist sehr lang. Ja, vor allem ist es so gut, es es wahrscheinlich so etwas, was du einfach irgendwie mal so nebenbei improvisiert hingeschrieben hast, einfach was kann ich, ja, Hebräisch kann ja jeder ein bisschen, ein Eis bestellen kriege ich gerade noch hin, und das kann eh niemand nachvollziehen, deswegen schreibe ich mal Hebräisch hin und Dialekte. Ja, ich könnte jetzt auch irgendwas sagen. Ja genau, das ist der Vorteil von Hebräisch, das kann einfach niemand nachvollziehen. Du kannst einfach dreimal husten und jeder sagt, wow, krass. Sag mal Hallo auf Hebräisch. Shalom. Sag mal, der Holocaust war eine Lüge? Der Holocaust hat nie stattgefunden. Das ist interessant, dass sie ein eigenes Wort dafür haben. Das ist komisch. Sollte man mal drüber nachdenken. Jetzt war mein Trick, ich habe überlegt, wie kann man testen, ob du wirklich Hebräisch sprechen kannst, weil das wahrscheinlich die erste Sprache ist, die man sofort aufschreiben würde, wenn man denkt, man braucht jetzt noch eine Sprache unbedingt, weil das niemand checken kann. Ich hätte dich in zehn Minuten nochmal gefragt nach dem Satz. Und dann hätte ich mir gemerkt, wie das erste klang und dann guckt, weil man würde sich hier niemals aufs Gleiche kommen. Ja, aber wie macht das denn? Du hast in deinem Lebenslauf Hebräisch stehen, du kannst nur Hallo sagen. Nein, gar nicht, das habe ich nicht gesagt. Was kannst du noch sagen? Aber ich kann es gar nicht mehr so gut. Bestell mal eine Falafel auf Hebräisch.
Nee, das kann ich auch nicht.
Da steht aber auch Grundkenntnisse in Klammern dahinter.
Ja, eine Falafel bestellen ist Grundkenntnisse für mich. Ja, in Köln, aber ... Ich weiß es auch nicht. Ich glaube, ich könnte nicht mal auf Deutsch eine Falafel bestellen, ehrlich gesagt. Was spricht sie hier immer? Falawala, Falawala. Falawala.
Was wollen Sie?
Nichts, eine Cola.
Zwei Cola.
Bälchen im Brot.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dein Lebenslauf ist ein Fala-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la Windsurfen und Snowboarden. Bühnenkampf kämpfst du da gegen die Bühne oder mit der Bühne oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Ja, da kämpfe ich mit dem Kopf gegen die Bühne. Und wer gewinnt da in der Regel? Ich. Schlecht. Windsurfen, was ist Windsurfen? Das ist das Uncoole, das Oper-Surfen, also mit so einem Segel dran. Das ist nicht uncool. So Sylt-Style, so. Ach, ich dachte, das ist, wenn man auf so einem Skateboard ist und dann übers Wasser gleitet. Nee, das sind die Kitesurfen. Ja, Kitesurfen. Genau, das ist cool, das würde ich auch mal gerne machen. Aber das ... Wie nennt man das, was die California Boys machen? Das ist so richtiges Surfen, oder? Heißt das richtiges Surfen? Was heißt cooles Surfen? Ja, okay. Aber nochmal zurück zum Bühnenkampf. Ich habe das Gefühl, da sind wir sehr schnell drüber hinweggegangen. Ja. Heißt das sowas, so Wrestling oder sowas? Hast du dann so eine Maske auf, so Raven Stereo-mässig und dann ... Nee, das wär geil. Nee, das ist einfach, wie man sich haut und schlägt, ohne dass man sich weht. Ach, okay. Und auch mit Stöcken als Schwert, ohne dass man sich aufspiesst, aber das ist halt sehr echt aussieht. Ach, wow. Es kommt auf Partys immer sehr gut, wenn man so tut, als würde man sich gerade gegenseitig. Aber nur wenn du es mit jemandem machst, der es auch beherrscht. Ja, ja. Der wundert sich ja einen Moment mal, ich werde gerade zusammengeklagen und spüre gar nichts. Das tut mir weh. Das ist nicht schlecht. Aber Bühnenkuss gibt es auch, dass man dann so tut, oder gibt es das nicht mehr? Ah, es ist halt ohne Zunge, sollte man glaube ich. Weil das habe ich mir, ich war mir nicht mal im Bavaria Filmstudio und dann wurden mir so Sachen erklärt, irgendwie wie so Sachen gemacht werden im Film, irgendwie dann dieses klassische, ja wenn ein Raum vibriert, dann vibriert nicht echt der Raum, sondern nur die Kamera und alle müssen dann irgendwie einen Herzanfall vortäuschen oder sowas. Und da gab es dann auch den Filmkuss und da wurden dann beide, Mann und Frau, so von vorne gezeigt, wie der Mann da die Lippen bewegen muss. Ich habe bis heute nicht genau verstanden, was das soll. Zum Beispiel wenn man sich ja in Filmen auf der Theater einfach wirklich küsst, so das ist ja auch jetzt. Ja, ja. Was ich gelernt habe, ist, dass man den Daumen vor den Mund des anderen nimmt, dass man den, dass man quasi so ... Ja gut, aber das merkst du ja irgendwie, wenn Ryan Gosling und Michelle Williams dann so endlich nach einem 90-minütigen Film ... Die ganze Hand zwischen das Gesicht zieht und Blatt Papier. Ja, ich küsste ihn wirklich. So kurz aus dem Husten raus in den Kuss gehen einfach direkt, das merkt man, glaube ich, schon. Ist es schon passiert, dass beim Küssen so die Hand dazwischen hängen geblieben ist und man dann dachte, jetzt zieht man es auch durch? Wie hängen geblieben? Ja, so einfach, man irgendwie wild gestikuliert hat und so bleibt es hängen, wie so eine Fliege. An den Lippen des anderen, ne was? Ja. Ist das noch nicht passiert? Das kann ich mir gerade nicht vorstellen. Warum stellst du die Frage so, als ob es das Normalste ist, was Menschen jemals passiert? Ja, wenn man halt irgendwie… Also ich kenne niemanden, der beim Film oder beim, vielleicht habe ich es immer falsch gemacht, aber mir wurde es, also man küsst sich wirklich, man versucht halt zu verzichten darauf, dass man da jetzt sehr viel Speichel in den anderen rein hämmert. Der Grund, warum wir das Theater machen, ist doch der, dass man seinen Schwarm küsst in der Schule, oder nicht? Definitiv, war bei mir auf jeden Fall so. Der Grund, in die Drama AG zu gehen, ist doch doch, die Lisa aus der 7B zu küssen endlich mal. Ja, vor allem das Krasse ist, es sind ja immer wesentlich mehr Frauen als Männer in der Theater-AG, und so war es bei mir auch. Und ich habe beim Theaterstück die Hauptrolle bekommen, und der hatte eben eine Kussszene, und dann sollte eben die weibliche Hauptrolle gecastet werden, und alle wollten die halt haben, das heisst, ich musste einfach die halbe Schule küssen, weil einfach alle, die die Rolle haben, und dann die Beispielszene, die alle spielen mussten, war genau die Kussszene, weil das so die dramatischste, am schwersten zu spielen war.
Da war bestimmt so eine Wette irgendwie abends, haben sie sich getroffen und dann so, ja okay, alles da, du musst dich bewerben und Florentin küssen. Ja genau, ey, wer das macht, nee, Alter, das ist ausgerechnet nicht. Oh nein, ey, das sagt nicht, okay, ich mach und dann, okay, Deutschland spielt zwei, zwei, eins, nein. Es gab noch eine zweite Männliche-Hauptrolle, die die zweite Besetzung gespielt hat, und der war als erstes, und ich dachte mir, die Kusszene tut man halt so, dass man küsst, und der hat halt einfach gnadenlos die Abgabe geknutscht. Ich dachte mir, ach du Scheiße, jetzt muss ich das auch machen, und musste halt irgendwie am Stück zwölf Mädchen küssen, so davor irgendwie noch nie, und dann einfach zwölf weggeballert irgendwie, von der schönsten der Schule bis zu der letzten irgendwie... Bis zur Sportlehrerin. Genau, bis zur Pausenstandverkäuferin einfach alle. Das war schon absurd, aber ja, das hat so zugehört. Ach so crazy Theatergeschichten, du hast Musical, machst du mit, ganz kurz mal eben, finde ich in deinem Lebenslauf nicht wieder. Aschenputtel. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das ein Musical ist. Aber gibt's einen bekannten Hit daraus? Nee. Aschenputtel, na na, Aschenputtel. Was war das nochmal für die Geschichte? Das war die mit dem Sch- Das war die mit dem Sch-Glasschuh. Die doch, wenn die Schuhe fits. Richtig wie er Smarties sortiert hat. Okay, also die, genau, und dann hat sie ein Glas und dann hat sie das Kleid aber nur für eine bestimmte Zeit auf dem ... Genau, und dann hat sie nach Mitternacht, so das ist dieses Disney.
Dann verliert sie da, genau, dann muss sie wieder in ihre Scheisswelt gehen.
Wer hat ihr das nochmal geschenkt, das Kleid? Warum, warum?
Die Fee. Die Fee, die du warst, hast du eben erzählt.
Ja.
Du hast ihr das Kleid geschenkt? Ja.
Geil.
Und auch die Taube warst du gleichzeitig.
Ja, die Taube wurde zur Fee quasi. Wer hat die Taube zur Fee gemacht? Der Regisseur. Moment, die höchste Instanz in jedem Märchenwald. Es ist immer so Fee, Zauberer, Nekromant, Drache, Regisseur einfach. Leute, hier, Grimms, wir müssen mal kurz miteinander reden. Ihr könnt nicht immer einen Regisseur reinschreiben, der immer entscheidet, was rauskommt. Der Regisseur wohnt im dunklen Wald und sieht die Schrift. Man sieht ihn nie, aber man weiß, er hat die Fäden in der Hand. Wenn der will, dann verlässt du die Bühne. Aschenputtel ab und ab geht's. Ich hab gelernt, man muss seit sechs Jahren Ballett und so eine Scheisse machen und halt so richtig krasse Lebensläufe haben und und so früh schon Gesangsausbildung und so. Ja, also ich bin ja auch jetzt eher überhaupt nicht so die Musical-Schiene. Vom Schauspiel kommst du dann wahrscheinlich, ja. Genau, aber man kann auch eine reine Musical-Ausbildung machen, das ist ja glaube ich früh in Hamburg. Genau, da lernt man aber halt auch viel mehr Tanz und Gesang, da ist der Schwerpunkt nicht so oft Schauspiel. Bei uns, wir haben, weiß ich nicht, zweimal die Woche Gesangsunterricht gehabt und zweimal die Woche Tanz und der Rest war aber dann auch nur Schauspiel. Und dann sehr lange den Kurs, wie man sich von der Taube in Menschen verwandelt. Genau. Das hat sehr viel Zeit eingenommen. Das war drei Semester von vier. Das wäre nicht schlecht. Und immer können Sie es wirklich einfach. Hast du dann auch, also so als, man kennt das ja so, dass Schauspieler sich so auf Rollen vorbereiten, um wirklich sich mit der Rolle zu identifizieren und wirklich die dunkelsten Ecken der Persönlichkeit zu erforschen. Hast du dich da auch viel mit Tauben beschäftigt und so, also um das adäquat darzustellen? Auf sie in die Stadt gegangen. Wie hast du das gemeint? Ja, in jeder Stadt habe ich mir die Tauben angeguckt, mit deren Verhalten studiert. Und was hast du für dich mitgenommen, was macht so eine Taube aus im Innersten? Ja, also es kommt halt wirklich dann auch auf die Stadt an, also die Ecken, am Bahnhof, es sind halt auch vom Leben gezeichnetere Tauben als im Park. Hören schlecht, ja. Ja. Im Park, das sind ein bisschen Snobbs, ne? man das Gefühl, auch so ein bisschen verwöhnt, immer sehr viel Brot. Ne, das Brötchen will ich nicht. Sehr viel Brot, Krümel um sich herumliegen. Sehr viel Brot. Ja, es gibt diese geile Geschichte von T.J. Miller, wie er im Park sieht, wie so ein älterer Herr ein sehr wertiges Brot, ein sehr, sehr gutes Brot, den Tauben gibt. Ein wertiges? Und zwar so ein gutes, wertiges Brot, dass T.J. Miller so getan hat, als wäre er eine Taube. und ist da, wollte er was für gutes Brot, den Tauben gibt. Und zwar so ein gutes, wertiges Brot, dass TJ Miller so getan hat, als wäre er eine Taube und wollte was für ein Bruder, und ist dann dahin gehüpft. Und dann hat der Typ ihm auch, weil er dachte, das wäre ein behinderter Mensch, hat ihm auch so ein Stück Brot. Wie man das ja mit behinderten Menschen hinlänglich macht, mit ein bisschen Brot in die Rache. Kannst du das mal machen, das Taubengurren? Das muss ich. Ich kann den … Wie gut denn eine Taube? Eine Parktaube oder so eine Banusstaube? Grrrr. Da, überrasch mich. Ab jetzt, den Rest des Podcasts machen wir nur noch als Taube. Ja. Ach, bei dir ist es mehr so ein Brrrr. Grrrr, grrrr, grrrr, grrrr, grrrr, gr machen die doch so richtig so. Nein. Nee, die haben immer so eine Melodie, wenn du auch wiedererkerkennt. Taube! Ich bin Taube, hey, schlaf mit mir, jetzt! Das wäre übersetzt der Brunftruf, einer männlichen Taube, oder nicht? Ich glaube nicht, dass die Schlaf mit mir sagen, ich glaube, die haben eine vulgäre. Fick mich, halt still! Obszöne Tauben, Stadttauben. Schlaf mit mir. Ah, du Rüpel, sagt dann die Armeise. Tor, du dummer Tor! Sagt dann der Spatz. Man könnte machen, also so wie Cats, aber halt nur mit Tauben, so Dobs. Einfach, dass man Cats eins zu eins noch mal erzählt. Oder halt dann irgendwie, erst mal macht man ein Musical mit Mäusen, dann werden die alle gefressen von Tauben. Gibt es nicht die Vogelhochzeit, die sehr nahe ran ist an dem, was wir gerade beschränken. Dann werden die alle gefressen von Cats, dann singen die Katzen weiter, dann werden die gefressen von so Geparden, dann singen die Geparden weiter und am Ende kommt so ein Traktor und dann singen die Traktoren und so. Dann kommen Züge und dann singen die Züge auf Rollstuhen, zum Beispiel in Bochum könnte man auch. Ja, das ist nicht schlimm. Dann werden die von Drachen irgendwie gefressen und dann geht es immer so weiter und das ganze Musical heisst Die Nahrungs-Cat. Wir sind beide mega ge geflasht, wir waren in New York und haben da Les Miserables gesehen
und wir singen seitdem nur noch, also auch privat, wenn ich Druckerpapier von ihm will,
wir brauchen sehr oft Druckerpapier in unserem Job, dann singe ich das die ganze Zeit,
wir waren echt erstaunt, wie krass das dann doch war, also performance-mäßig, bühnenmäßig. Der Drucker ist schon wieder leer, dann hol halt neues Papier, werden wir die Tinte finden. Nein, nein. Ist ein bisschen besser mit Backup-Singer, muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Ja, ne ich finde Musical, ich will das dann nicht so abwerten, ich finde Musical cool, ich habe nur noch nicht so viele coole gesehen. Du bist eher so ein Surfer-Girl einfach. Und Wind-Surfer-Girl. Wind ist für dich einfach dein Leben, oder? Das ist total mein Leben. Das ist genau deins. Einfach raus auf die Wellen, einfach den Wind genennen. Woran siehst du dich in fünf Jahren? Ja, irgendwas Kreatives auf der Bühne oder... Aber Comedy, du bist hauptsächlich hier, weil wir dich gesehen haben, bei Nightwatch. Ja. Weil wir halt ... Also wir wollen schon langfristig den Comedystandort Deutschland verbessern. Bislang mit geringem Erfolg, aber ... Also wir haben den einen oder anderen Rückschlag. Viele Rückschläge, wir haben viel auch kaputt gemacht. Viele staatsanwaltschaftliche Probleme. Florentin selbst hat sehr viel zerstört, Comedy-Landschaft Deutschland. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Aber wir haben gehofft, dass du, aber du machst nicht mehr so viel Stand-up hast du, Stand-up, wollte ich jetzt sagen. Stand-up. Machst du nicht mehr so viel? Ja, jetzt gerade nicht so genau, weil die Zeit ein bisschen... Aber wir wollen dich schon zwangsläufig wieder dahin bringen. Ja, das wäre sehr cool. Weil es wäre echt cool. Weil es gibt einfach nicht viele Leute, die auch coole Vorbilder haben in Deutschland und das halt so machen, als wäre es was Cooles. Was ist das dein Vorbilder-Stand-up-mäßig gewesen? Ich feiere Oliver Polack. Früher war es natürlich so Anke Engelke, so klassisch. Genau, ich finde, Karolin Kebekus ist, genau. Gut, also was war das für eine Geste? Ach so, ja, man sieht das nicht. Ihr habt gesagt, ich soll auch was zeigen. Stimmt, das war jetzt unsere Webcam. Wenn wir Glück haben, war es genau um voll, dass die Webcam das gesehen hat. Wo? Wo ist die? Ich glaube in sieben Minuten ist es wieder soweit. Mach die Geste jetzt noch kurz mal für fünf Minuten, dann sind wir sicher, dass es die Webcam gefolgt hat. Halt sie mal!
Ja, nein, finde ich gerade die beste Frau, was Comedy in Deutschland gerade angeht.
Ja, das ist echt schade irgendwie, dass es da nichts gibt.
Ja, das ist halt blöd, aber... Es gibt keine lustigen Frauen, ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Jetzt auch auf den Spuckschutz hier aufgepasst. Sehr gut, dafür ist er da, dafür ist er da. Das war jetzt eher so ein Filmkuss ans Mikrofon. Sehr trocken. Ja, komm mal jetzt gut durch. Ich hab zu wenig Wasser hier in der Hand. Warte, ich kann dir noch drei weitere Gläser geben. Ja, bitte. Aber stimmt das, dass man sich den Text manchmal in die Klamotten des anderen reinschreibt? Das heißt, wenn man eine Kussszene hat oder so eine Umarmungsszene, dass man dann in eine Nackenpartie des anderenpartie des anderen Im Schild hier im Etikett. Genau, genau, da würde ich mir einen Text reinschreiben. Nicht bügeln, nein, falsch. Nur bei 30 Grad waschen. Du schreibst es auf die Pupillen des anderen, kannst dann während du ihm in die Augen guckst, kannst dann ablesen, aber spiegelverkehrt. Ja, alle fragen sich, warum hat er nichts gesehen, der Hauptdarsteller, warum war der blind, warum er so rote stechende Augen gab. Ja gut, ich brauch halt irgendwo einen Spicker. Hast du gespickt in der Schule? Ja. Warst du so ein richtiger Spicker? Ja. Wie hast du es gemacht, was war dein Trick? So ganz doof im Taschenrechner. Ich hatte... Ach ja, die Casio, Klassik... Nee, noch nicht mal, ich hatte diesen, wie heisst der, ich war Realschule. Da gab es diesen... Er gänzt sich kurz dann den Deckel abnehmen und dann den da wieder reinschieben und dann hatte man wie so ein Fach. Und das war bei mir immer voll mit Spicker und das hat niemand gerafft. Du konntest aber einfach in die Hosentasche stecken, weil Lehrer dürfen nicht in die Hosentaschen reinfassen. Oder unter'n Rock, dachte ich mir immer. So als Frau kann man das ja so auf den Oberschenkel einfach kleben.
Weil ja kein Lehrer der Welt würde sagen, hey, lass mich mal unter deinen Rock schauen. Ja, aber ja. Also da hast du ja wirklich keine Chance. Ich habe manchmal, wenn ich was zu trinken mit hatte, habe ich mir in das Etikett das reingeschoben, sieht niemand einfach. Boah, ich hatte auch mal stimmt, ich hatte so einen Kulli, so einen Kugelschreiber, da konnte man sowas rausziehen.
Ja, ja, mega fies.
Das ist Schieten. Das ist Schieten.
Das sind wirkliche Spickinstrumente.
Also Spicken ist so ein Schieten, okay?
Nein, Leute, schau mal.
Wo versteckt man eine Leiche? Auf einem Schlachtfeld.
Keller.
Wo versteckt man einen Diamanten? Im Kronleuchter.
Man versteckt die Dinge immer da, wo sie eigentlich an der Oberfläche liegen. Meine Strategie war irgendwann... Schinkenspicker, wo willst du jetzt genau Spicker? Nein, irgendwann habe ich angefangen, einfach weil du kriegst ja dann so ein Blatt ausgehändigt und dann halt so einen Aufgabenzettel und dann schreibst du da drauf. Und irgendwann habe ich einfach dieses Blatt eins zu eins nachempfunden und habe das einfach vollgeschrieben und habe irgendwann einfach dann den Spicker positioniert unter meiner Bank und dann habe ich das Blatt bekommen und habe es dann einfach im Moment, wo der Lehrer nicht hingeguckt hat, unter das andere Blatt getan und hat einfach zwei Blätter. Das ist eine aufwendige Bewertung. Das hat niemand gemerkt, weil du siehst ja, okay, das sind zwei Blätter und du musst es nicht verstecken. Ich glaube, du verrätst dich eher durch diese, ich muss jetzt irgendwo hingucken und scheiße, jetzt habe ich Lehrerin geguckt. Und einfach wenn du so tust, als wäre es das Selbstverständlichste der Welt, dass du halt schon einen Zettel voll geschrieben hast, dann ist das überhaupt kein Problem. Also alle, die jetzt noch in der Schule sind, schaut euch mal an, einfach to hide in plain sight. Aber wie kam es auf Hebräisch? Warum Hebräisch?
Boah, ich habe viel gelesen. Nee, ich fand das irgendwie, fand ich die Sprache interessant. Ich weiss aber auch gar nicht, wann, warum, wieso. Dann habe ich mir ein, dann war irgendwo, ich weiss gar nicht mehr, wo ich war, in, habe ich ein Buch gefunden und das war irgendwie runtergesetzt und das war Hebräisch und dann habe ich gedacht, ich hole mir das jetzt irgendwie einfach mal und lese mich so ein bisschen rein. What? Wow. Ich glaube, man kann die hebräische Kultur nicht mehr beleidigen als, warum hast du dich für die reichhaltige und interessante Kultur Hebräer satt. Ja, aber was soll ich denn jetzt sagen? Ja, das war runtergesetzt, das war ein Mangelexemplar, das lag da bei Lidl an der Kasse, ich mitgenommen habe es gelernt. Ja, aber warum soll ich das denn sonst? Ihr habt jetzt irgendwie so eine ganz deep Story erwartet. Ja, wir dachten, dass sich irgendwas verbindet mit dir und Hebräon. Nee, also ich fand die Sprache irgendwie, ich fand sie schön und dann hat mich dieses Buch angelacht und dann habe ich gedacht. Ja, glaube ich dir nicht. Das ist mir egal. Okay, aber ich kauf's dir nicht ab. Du würdest aber langfristig auch gerne da leben, in Hebräien. Hebräienland. In Hebräien, ne. Das ist nichts für dich. Ne, das ist mir ein bisschen zu spät. Du würdest eher so Richtung, na warte, sagt nichts, ich glaube, du gehst eher so in Richtung Kapstadt, sowas. Das ist eher dein? Griechenland. Kapstadt liegt in Griechenland. Holland fände ich gut. Holland. Zu leben auch? Ja, irgendwie schon. Ich fände Amsterdam, also Amsterdam ist eine meiner Lieblingsstädte und ich mag die Niederländer sehr gerne. Okay, Entschuldigung. Und ist nicht so weit weg. Aber das ist, das finde ich dann wieder ein Downer eigentlich. Eigentlich will man doch wo weit weg, man will ein bisschen Eskapismus betreiben, wo kann man hin, wo, was ist weit weg, was ist unerreichbar, aber eigentlich doch erreichbar mit einem Billigflieger in ein paar Stunden bezahlbar, erreichbar. Und wo gibt's dann noch gute Hotels bei hotel.de. Ja, wie er wie die. Drei oder mehr Sternen. Mit mehr als 86 Prozent Weiterempfehlungen. Und wo will Thomas hin, der ja dann irgendwie nicht so weit weg will, aber dann auch irgendwie ein bisschen was erleben will und … Dann seine Freundin wieder anruft und sagt, was ist mit dir eigentlich los, Thomas? Ach, Alter, Alter, gib mir das. jedes mal ja voll meine socken sind glaube ich immer noch nass ach aber das ist das tut mir leid aber nasse socken finde ich manchmal ist auch ganz angenehm eigentlich so hat so was frisches irgendwie so ein bisschen so als würde man wie frisch gewaschen als würde man wie als würde man stehen. Sagt ihr Socken oder Strümpfe?
Socken.
Ich sage Socken zu Socken und Strümpfe zu Strümpfen.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Socken und Strumpfen?
Strümpfe sind länger.
Wie eine Strumpfhose, oder?
Nein.
So halterlose Strümpfe.
Strümpfe können aber auch relativ...
Ich glaube, das kommt auf dem Dialekt so ein bisschen an.
Also ich kenne auch aus dem Bayerischen, dass man nur Strümpfe sagt, Socken da eher weniger.
Söckchen. Ja, Söckchen. Söckelchen. Oder halt Sock, je nachdem. Sock. Sock. Von Sack abgeleitet einfach, dass man früher hat man ja in Säcken geschlafen. Völlig verrannt, auch nicht. Und noch eine Meta-Ebene mehr. So kennen wir dich. Metaflow. Insekten haben wir auch viel gemacht viel gemacht. Ich bin komplett raus, ciao! Danke, dass du da warst, danke, dass wir dich kennenlernen durften, Sabrina Sauer, Comedienne. Nächster Auftritt, komm, wir machen den nächsten Stand-Up-Auftritt. Wann ist der nächste Stand-Up-Auftritt? Wir wollen nicht mal wieder live sehen. Unsere Hörer sind Comedy-Liebhaber, die wollen nicht mal wieder live sehen. 2018, 2017, wo? Ja, 17, 18. Schaubühne, Essen.
In Köln, im, wo in Köln? Im Pipo, im Calamari, im Underground, im Boom, im Boing gibt's wirklich, ja. Das Boing gibt's wirklich. Siegidi Bing Bang, wo zieht sich hin? Ja. Sag einfach jetzt mal eine Bandje. Boing! Im Boing, 2017 im Boing, geil, wir freuen uns. Boioioioio, vielen Dank, dass du da warst, Sabrina Sauer. Wir konnten immer noch nicht hinter das Geheimnis deines Namens steigen. Unter der Hebräisch-Geschichte, die ich immer noch nicht abkaufe. Dafür müssen wir dann dein neues Buch lesen. Wie heißt das, wo kann man das kaufen? Das heisst, äh, Windsurfen in Hebräien. Alles klar, cool, für 4,99 Euro runtergesetzt bei Lidl.
Leider auf Hebräisch, aber da können wir die Sprache lernen.
Bis dann, macht's gut, ciao, wir sind ein Ufo und heben am Ende immer ab.
Das heisst, wir heben jetzt ab. Thank you.